[موسيقى]
نتيجه للسدود التركيه الكبيره بسبب مشروع
القلب 22
الايراني
الحصه المائيه العراقيه بشكل واضح جدا
اضافه الى دخول المياه الى داخل الاراضي
العراقيه تاسرت مع وضع التغيرات المناخيه
مثل انخفاء شديد في معدلات الامطار خلال
الفتنات العشره الماضيه همم وجود بقع على
التصحر ارتفاع معدلات درجات الحراره هذا
ادت جميعا بشكل تازر الى خفض مناسيب
المياه في حوض دجله والفرات
[موسيقى]
مما يحتم الحكومه العراقيه ان تاخذ مجموعه
من الاجراءات خلال السنوات العشر القادمه
خاصه بعد تصريح وزاره الموارد المائيه ان
حوضي دجله والفرات سيبدا بالشحه والنقص
الكبير في مستوى المياه خلال عام 20 30 22
40 ممكن ان ينتهي الى حد كبير بعدم وجوهنا
رئيس الدوله والفرات على على الارض او على
الواقع خلال هذه الفتره
[موسيقى]
هناك يعني
معاهدات
[موسيقى]
يعني تشاطئ على النهار في كل العالم لكن
هذه الامور نشفت من قبل الجارتين الحقيقه
وان نحن دعونا كالجنه زراعه ومن
برنامجنا ومن عملنا في هذه اللجنه الى
تشكيل
لجنه عليا هي علياء
لاداره الملف المائي
[موسيقى]